NIKO SCHROER: Hello, everybody.
Good afternoon.
My name is Niko Schroer.
I'm a partnerships manager in
the Play Apps Team based here
in Berlin, and it's a
great, great pleasure
to have all of you here today.
For a while now, I've
been really focusing
on the topic of subscriptions,
and it's actually
pretty amazing to see
how far the subscription
business on Google Play has come
and how well it has developed.
Since we got together for a
Playtime last time in 2016,
so about one year
ago, we've actually
onboarded over 3,200
new subscription
services to Google Play.
Half of them, which are
completely new apps,
with the other half coming
from existing apps which
started offering subscriptions.
This includes developers,
such as VKontakte from Russia,
[INAUDIBLE] from France,
Flight Radar 24 from Sweden,
or even Supercell's game Boom
Beach to just name a few.
So clearly, subscriptions
are having a great momentum.
And proven point--
you're being here.
We are having a more
and more full house.
And if you attended
any of our events
before, Playtime, Google I/O,
or an industry-specific event,
you should be pretty familiar
with our subscriptions
offering.
So for today, we don't want
to bore you with the basics.
We don't want to bore an
expert audience with repeating
this stuff over and over again.
Instead, we will
share insights on how
you can take your subscriptions
business to the next level.
So we will talk about how you
can outsmart subscriptions.
As every business
grows, it starts
facing its own challenges.
So when it comes to
subscription businesses,
we hear from you
about such things
as declining
payments from users,
the difficulty of figuring
out the right balance
between features
and price points,
or churning subscribers, and
the issues of winning them back.
So for today's
session, we took 10
of the most common challenges.
We hear from you--
the developers
we work with-- on
a day to day basis.
And we structure them
in three buckets--
the buckets that make up
your subscriptions revenue.
So for the next
15 to 20 minutes,
we will share some solutions
to help you outsmart them.
Let's start with the tricky
top of the funnel acquisition
on conversion.
A first challenge we
hear is that developers
don't know where the
subscribers are coming from--
which markets, which
channels, or which devices.
And therefore, they are
unable to optimize that value
proposition unless performing
markets double down
in the highest converting
markets or targeting
more lucrative devices.
So over the last
few months, we've
launched several
subscription specific reports
in the Google Play Console to
allow you to easily deep dive
into all of that.
The user acquisition
reports in the Play Console
allow you to understand
the markets that
drive the highest install
and subscriptions, which
acquisition channels are
most effective in driving
subscriptions for you, how
your subs are performing
along the whole funnel, and
very importantly-- also,
how you're performing
against your peers.
So all of that is extremely
useful information
for you to optimize your
subscription acquisition
strategy.
Challenge number two-- we
often hear from developers
is that not enough
users perceive the value
of becoming a subscriber.
So we have two solutions we
want to suggest for that.
First is to make sure you
promote your value proposition
at various touch
points within the app,
and especially during
the onboarding.
Health and fitness
app Freeletics
redesigned the
onboarding to emphasize
the value proposition, which
is getting a user really fit,
rather than the app's features,
and this increased conversion
by 10% for them.
Language learning app Memorize
prompts upsell opportunities
based on user activity.
So what that means
is they detect
what is the best moment to
highlight premier features.
For example, somebody keeps
tapping on the audio button
to replay spoken words.
That then triggers an
upsell prompt to highlight
audio mode, which is a
subscription-only feature.
And they have similar pop-ups
linked to specific interactions
on screen.
So once they detect a user
is doing a certain activity
in the app, that
triggers the upsell.
So very intuitive and
very natural to the user
to then go to a subscription.
Another solution is
a pretty common one.
It's offering a
free trial to get
users to try before they
buy it Our user study shows
that 78% of subscribers
start with a free experience.
Oh, and as we announced
in the keynote,
you have asked us for
shorter free trial periods,
and we have listened.
So now, you can offer
three-day free trials
instead of the minimum of
seven, which we had before.
So this could be really
relevant for businesses
with high marginal costs.
Challenge number three we hear
from developers about users
abandoning the purchase flow.
And unless this
is the first time,
you're attending
any of our events
or speaking to anybody
of us from the team,
you would probably have heard
our recommendations before.
Implement Google Play billing.
Implement Google Pay
billing to offer your users
multiple payment options across
over 130 countries globally
and the trusted, reliable, and
frictionless two-step checkout
process.
And beyond that,
starting January 1, 2018,
we're updating our
transaction fee
for subscribers who are
retained for more than 12
paying months to 15% to
recognize developers who
maintain longstanding
subscribers
and create great
user experiences.
Challenge number four is related
to have users hanging around
in the free tier without
ever making a payment.
A good solution
for that would be
to use introductory pricing to
offer periodic sales to users.
Cookpad, which is a super
popular cooking app in Japan,
ran a 50% discount
during Ramadan,
and it led to a 4.5x increase
in data subscriptions versus
a comparable period.
In fact, we are
seeing many successes
with introductory pricing.
And many of the
developers we speak
to now consider it a
key marketing tool.
Now, let's move on to the
next bucket of challenges--
those related to
retention and recovery.
And to me, personally,
it's another great sign
that we get more and
more questions about this
because it also means that
your business has grown
so much that this is actually
a major point of questions
and feedback we get from you.
So starting with
the challenge we
hear from almost every developer
in some shape or form--
trouble of retaining
subscribers.
It is really something
everybody talks about,
and everybody tries to optimize.
And that is very straightforward
because improving retention
rate is so crucial to the
bottom line of a subscription
business.
And therefore, we want
to offer two solutions
you could use to optimize
your retention rate overall.
The first solution
is to give users
something to nurture by
gamifying the user experience.
And I completely appreciate that
when I mention gamification,
the buzzword alerts--
the risk of the buzzword alert
going off is really high.
So let's go through
some best practices
to add some color
what we mean by that.
First, it's important
that you measure
your users' engagements versus
the engagement objectives
that you have defined.
Second, you want to make sure
to surface this to the user
and allow the user to
actually show it off.
For example, in their profile.
Another way to think about it
is to incorporate in-app rewards
or real savings for users
hitting engagement milestones,
and then you can deincentivize
subscription churn
by making valuable rewards
available for subscribers-only.
Language learning app
Duolingo successfully
incorporates many of these
mechanics into the app.
So if you want to get some
inspiration, download the app
and check it out and
see what they do.
Also, it's peer memorized,
which I've mentioned before,
offers discounts to users
who hit certain milestones.
So they're putting the last
best practice I mentioned right
into practice.
Again, if you're looking
for some inspirations,
I recommend you to check it out.
The second solution
to optimizing churn
is more straightforward.
It's to offer users
longer period plans
and to present
them convincingly.
Some tips on how to do that.
First, make sure your
multi-frequency plan
is available at cost savings
versus the monthly plan.
Second, present the
equivalent monthly price
to highlight the cost savings.
So it's easy for
the user to compare
and very straightforward to
see what they're actually
getting for committing
for a longer period.
Three, funnel all
your promotions
as seasonal campaigns to
those long period plans.
The Korean [? Aswot ?]
platform Watch or Play
diversified from
one option, which
was monthly, to four options--
one month, three,
six, and 12 month
and found that 40%
of the users actually
choosing a multi-month option.
So the next challenges
that come up
when it's technically too late.
It's too late because your
subscribers have churned,
but the solutions
we will show you
are probably the most
requested as we've
heard from you over the
last couple of months
and probably a year.
So the first churn
challenge we usually hear
is that you have a
hard time figuring out
why a subscriber has churned.
As announced at Google
I/O, the new churn reports
in the Play Console
give you visibility
into the churn reasons.
For example, is it voluntary
churn, involuntary churn,
or whether users also deleted
the app after canceling?
But an even bigger challenge
we've heard from you
is that you don't know when
your subscribers are churning.
So we're really excited to
present real-time developer
notifications.
As Kobe talked about already
in the keynote this morning,
it's our new feature that
immediately informs you
of any change in
subscribers states, sorry.
So for example, cancellation,
suspension, et cetera so
you can act on it immediately.
So when subscribers
have left and now
that you can be
notified in real-time,
you could actually craft
your win back message
and reach out to
churn subscribers
to pitch the benefits of
your subscriptions again
and to try to win them back.
Anghami, a music streaming
service in the Middle East,
optimizes the in-app
messaging to churn subscribers
to really emphasize
the premium features
they are missing out on.
For example here
in the screenshot,
you see the bring
back your 38 downloads
which is a subscription only
feature for Anghami users.
Similarly, brain
training Lumosity
sends churned users
emails to notify them
about new content as
a win back strategy.
And to close the
whole win back loop,
we're now making restoring
a subscription much easier
with a new subscription
restoration
feature on Google
Play billing, which
we announced this morning.
So to quickly recap these
last couple of challenges
and solutions, combined this
gives you a full subscriber
win back solution.
The subscriber cancels.
We send you, the developer,
a real-time notification
about that.
You, the developer,
then send a message
to the churned subscriber
and if successful,
the subscriber can go back and
restore their subscription.
All of that at Google Play
billing, pretty cool, huh?
So we are constantly
investing in improving
features related to
win back, so stay
on the lookout on this topic.
While all of that covered
the voluntary cancellation
quite well, what about the users
that didn't even want to cancel
but whose payment
happened to get
declined because their
credit card expired,
the transaction didn't
go through, et cetera?
Again, we have two solutions.
These two solutions can be used
separately or in combination.
The first one is to
enable grace period.
If you haven't
enabled grace period,
you can basically go into
your Google Play Console
and tick the box right now.
By enabling grace
periods in the console,
you grant users an extra
three or seven days
to fix payment issues.
And at the aggregate level
across all developers,
we see that those
two activate grace
periods see a 50% improvement
in renewal decline recovery.
It is such a simple but
effective optimizations
you all can do basically now.
And if you think granting
a grace period to use
is not enough, and the user
may need in addition motivation
to update their
form of payments,
you can switch on account
holds to put subscribers
in a suspended state until they
update their form of payments.
See that notification
that Univision now
pops up at two users whose
payment has been declined.
From there, it
directly deep links
into the form of payment
update flow in the Play Store.
So whenever they use the fixes
their form for any payments
on Google Play, their
suspended subscriptions
will be reinstated immediately.
And as we announced
this morning,
this feature of
Google Play billing
is now open to all developers.
Dating at Tindr has
been an early tester
and actually seen a 3x
increase in payment recovery
since implementing account hold.
So with all these new
and exciting solutions
to outsmart
retention challenges,
let's not forget about pricing.
Finding the right price for any
product is a science in itself.
So no surprise, we
quite often hear
that you're wondering if
you price it correctly,
or if you're actually
leaving money on the table.
So we want to run through
three solutions of how
you can optimize that part.
First, we recommend that you
test price points with the help
of Firebase Remote Config.
You can set up two more SKUs,
surface them to different user
groups, and compare metrics to
find out which performs better.
When doing that, please
remember that the goal
is to maximize retention
and not just the sign-up.
So it may take a couple
of months for you
to actually figure out which
one works better in that regard.
Solution number two is
to offer multiple plans
with varying sets of features.
Entertainment app
CBS successfully
does cater to different
audiences' willingness
to pay with two different plans.
One where you get the content
with limited commercials,
and one where it's completely
out of here, and both
are at different price points.
And then solution
number three is
to use the plan
upgrade and downgrade
feature of Google Play billing
to let subscribers seamlessly
move between the plans.
Again, entertainment
app CBS does this
successfully with their
limited commercials
versus no commercial
sell on plans.
So if a subscriber decides
that a price point of let's say
$9.99 a month is too much,
instead of having them churn,
you give them the option to
kind of downgrade to $4.99.
And obviously, you
can do it vice versa
and increase the basket
size and lifetime value.
So I completely appreciate.
This has been a lot of content
in a short period of time,
and it's an afternoon session.
However, let me quickly recap.
We presented one
or more solutions
to 10 common
subscription challenges
to outsmart subscriptions
across the complete user flow.
As the next step,
we, of course, want
you to put these solutions into
action and to make this as easy
as possible for you.
We actually summarized all of
them in a handy one-sheeter.
I think it's actually
two sheets but anyways--
which you can
download on this link.
I give you 20 seconds
to take a picture.
And because sometimes you
like to kick it old-school,
we also have a
printed out version,
which you can pick
up at the front,
and we're going to
have laying out later.
So you can take it
back to your teams,
put it up in your
office, and start
getting busy with
implementing these solutions.
That's it for me.
I really hope the
session was useful.
Thank you very much
for paying attention.